[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
madame monsieur bonsoir
si je me pensais alors je veux pour se
voir je me levais à
savoir si on
décèle aussi
je me souviens que lorsque j'étais
encore un enfant
jarman une fois ma mère ou magie à
l'avenue fait de noël pour l'achat de la
cgt et louis marc il a joué qu il se
trouvait j'aurais bien aimé même en
super g malheureusement faute de loi est
capable d'oublier tant sa priorité ce
jour là était de nous percevoir dans les
dom c était
comme un enfant j'ai pleuré j'aime des
gemmes c'est une grande frustration
du fait que je ne vais pas avoir un
jouet comme mes amours
je suis sûr que la plupart d'entre vous
qui allez déjà un motif de frustration
parfois réseau de chaînes
moyens aussi ou encore raison de leur
état ou bien
marquer les mots
mais face à ces situations
que ça dit de vos frustrations
un coup d'oeil à ceux qui préfèrent le
ministre
pourquoi ces personnes qui ont un esprit
de confiance
pour cette nation qui se consacre à
mettre du temps à ressasser leur douleur
ou bien fait parce que vous faites
partie de ces personnes qui au contraire
concerne la frustration qui va
chacun de vous me répondre à ses désirs
me concernant j'ai fait mes frustrations
dérivés que des rubriques j'utilise
n'ont pas manqué un but face à les
objectifs mais le faire dès cette année
que je
franchis bazana faut un bel âge de la
vie
[Musique]
fm on s'est arraché avec moi quand je
suis passé de la jeune fille
qui vivait avec ce truc droit à la liste
2.0 la logique qui est né citer çà et là
mais bon si j'arrivais l'âme des
nombreux fonctionnait pas un coup de
magie
j'ai franchi plusieurs sénateurs avant
se fixer
il avoue
j'ai dû stopper mes études un coupable
de faute de moyens financiers
mais dans cette adversité
plutôt que de rester dans mon coin et de
leurs enfants j'ai commencé à chercher
des opportunités
pour avoir un hangar de son talent
présidée par issa laye
avant ce succès j'aide allons marcher
dessus sous le soleil
parfois se battre ensemble et c'est ma
vie est inutile et le transport de deux
mois les batailles aux arrêts et
demandait trop petit gène
avant ce succès ils ont su d'amour
devront tirer
des roquettes à l'esprit autrement dit
j'ai des victimes de regniowez sociaux
en raison de mes yeux dimanche
pour
cette dame mais moi j'ai vu ton info
lundi vient
oui
c'est bon
et je suis les obstacles juste un mot ni
la première ni jour dans l'histoire de
la mode y voir
mes jeunes arrêtés mais aussi par le
travail par la fois la confiance ce soir
je ne peux pas une chose évidente non je
vais travailler faire des logis et je
veux vous dire en ce jour que si cela a
dénoncé mme roy cela est aussi possible
si je te dis lyonnais à la retenue et
non je passe par là je veux ton j'avais
déjà l'établissement de permettre
d'avoir au 1 million sous mon col à cet
âge là rihanna le plan que j'avais n'est
pas celui qui est à vis mon programme
était je suis ton après mon stage la
logique à la demie obtenir
gloire et ponot mise et vous allez vous
parlera que restent prudents et tout
cela j'ai crié on passe le pouvoir quand
on veut quelque chose de mettre dans les
dispositions de cette chose vous ne
pouvez pas demander à mesure de vous
permettre d'avoir deux fois sur six ne
parle pas
de vous permettre d'avoir des voyages à
l'étranger s'ils valent pas le minimum
des placements et tout j'écris beaucoup
trop et j'ai réellement avoir son temps
plein mais la mitidja le jour et des
continuités d'avoir des idées mais
malgré cela je n'ai pas cessé de quoi
dans cette vision selon laquelle je
voulais avoir empoigné millions et
montclos que j'avais établi ne passait
plus avec moi owen tous les objectifs
que je m'étais fixé à la fin de l'année
2009 se sont réalisées à la fin de
l'année 2001 qui jouent la finale de
mise à l'eau
la mairie nous a jamais dit à nous
c'est aussi ça a été possible noir et
c'est aussi aussi beaux jours ce mot
c'est une foule d'arras huntelaar ou de
l'étudiant vous chargez temps c'est
aussi pour vous de franchir l obstacle
qui sont sur votre chemin oui je sais
mais ça possible uniquement si vous
prenez pour ceux d'amiens ce que vous
êtes dessus apprendre à l'immigré si
vous menez les actions qu'il faut
oublier bien évidemment ça fera en finit
5e aussi pouvoir et aujourd'hui je parle
d'abord devoir partager ma passion pour
les technologies
aucune fille n'a été possible moi la
meilleure parmi les étudiants en
informatique de mon école alors que les
idéaux types nous faisait deux mois que
ce domaine elle est l'aînée pause on
s'est dit aussi pour - alençon c'est
aussi pour vous je voudrais qu'à la vue
de mon étal sont si vous n'obtenez rien
de tout ce que j'ai dit vous reteniez de
samoa souliers c'est aussi parce que
pour moi seront dès ce mois que vous ne
vous aimez c'est celui inventé ce mois
nous invitait les enfants qui peut vous
permettre d'aller de la louer
genièvre disent ne pas battre le temps
c'est bien ce tracé qui vous bloque
encore je joue seriez vous tous c'est
lourd de la sfl mois l'agencé xinhua
soit sept travaillent réellement c'est
croire jeu sur tout et vous tous c'est
d'avoir ou non un candidat les limitent
pas à l'otan planifient malgré de la vie
afin d'arriver l'arrosage barnier c'est
beau c'est sa voix société c'est aussi
une fois de plus soudé que si vous vous
le processus pourrait recevoir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]